hello everyone and this is gerald from
geek culture we'll be going through the
lg c1 today to get an understanding of
how it fares as a day-to-day monitor for
productivity gaming and entertainment
while many folks use a tv daily what if
you could use it for more than just
watching movies and tv shows
after much research the 48 inch lg c1 is
presently one of the best tvs to get
with an amazing oled display plenty of
hdmi 2.1 ports being able to use it for
more than most of the day leaks out
plenty of value for this tv however
given the size it might be quite
overkill for folks to use as a monitor
plenty of consideration and tools have
to be deployed to make the most of the
lg c1 to ensure it goes the distance
before we begin thanks for sticking
around and be sure to like and hit the
bell icon your support goes a long way
first of all let's go through the basics
of the monitor
the lg c1 is the company's latest range
of 2021 tvs
it features lg's a9 gen 4 ei processor
4k which leverages on a deep learning
tech to help analyze and optimize
content paired with 100 million self-lit
pixels users will be able to achieve
perfect blacks and color at all times
have a look for yourself
the tv comes in a variety of sizes and
at 48 inches it is the smallest and
lightest of the range
i output the c1 at the maximum
resolution of 3840 by 2160 and achieving
120 frames per second without a hitch
the real estate is a plenty and it might
be challenging for a regular user to
make the most of it it runs on lg's web
os and i find it pretty comparable to
the android tv ui
and with its supplied controller making
it quick and snappy to navigate around
menus be it via the button controls or
you can wave it around like a laser
pointer all your favorite streaming apps
are here from netflix disney plus and
youtube using the lg c1 has my daily
driver i had to do some prep work
beforehand
weighing in at 15 kg i've chosen it to
be mounted on an ergotron hx test mount
give me some flexibility in adjusting
the display easily and smoothly you'll
also need a visa mount to go along with
this links are in the description below
as you can see the display is huge when
used this close so much so that the
camera i use for calls is mounted right
on the top which might lead to odd
camera angles
with the desk mount i've been able to
free up some space on the table to
prevent it from looking too cluttered
this is a 60 inch desk
so it should give you an idea how a 48
inch lg c1 might fit in your setup often
i'm sitting about 74 centimeters away
from the screen which i feel is a
comfortable distance the previous
monitor was a 34 inch ultra wide curved
display so transitioning to the bigger
lg c1 took a bit of getting used to in
the day-to-day i rely on an application
called power toys fancy zones to help me
arrange my windows i split up the entire
display into 12 zones and work off the
middle zones the most this gives me a
working resolution of about 2194 by
1264. combine that with two more windows
either side which i use for my chats and
email is more than sufficient with such
large screens the idea is to limit how
much you need to move your head reducing
neck strain when it comes to working off
applications like premiere pro and
photoshop there's plenty of space for
one to move the timeline and canvas
while referring to notes at the same
time this improves productivity overall
but let's be honest here the real reason
why you should be considering the lg c1
in the first place is how it supports
both nvidia g-sync and sample hdmi 2.1
ports if you are someone who owns a ps5
xbox series x and a rtx 3080 pc at the
same time this should be the tv that
will be on the top of your list the only
drawback here
is you'll be getting a maximum 120
frames per second only for me i've used
this tv daily and made full use of it
with g-sync and an rtx 3080 considering
that 4k gaming at higher frame rates is
rather new to our console brothers there
are very little tv alternatives right
now in the market which can support such
a wide breadth of cases like the lg c1
transitioning from pcus is seamless and
lg has their own game optimizer mode
which new users will need to toggle to
get the most out of the cv by default
these settings will not be set
accordingly out of the box this is
especially important for input lag and
you'd want to definitely turn this on
for games such as fps titles fighting
games so that the tv matches your
reaction
if you're looking for a tv that does
really well for gaming look no further
than the lg c1 what we have here is the
variable refresh rate otherwise known as
vrr that really makes all the games look
as well as they should be especially on
modern consoles
this means the lg c1 will always try its
best to output at the maximum console
refresh rate at all times the lg c1 also
has a 1ms response time which matches
what we have with other gaming monitors
out there outside of gaming the lg c1 is
naturally a great fit for all your
entertainment needs from netflix to
disney plus it supports dolby vision and
at most and there will be a nice pop-up
that appears once you are viewing
content that supports these features
when watching shows i will actually
slide back further and kick up my feet
to enjoy the content the colors and
blacks with the lg c1 exactly the level
of quality we have come to expect from
the company the great thing about this
is the tv knows exactly what you're
consuming at a specific point of time
and changes your display settings
accordingly if you're hopping between
netflix console gaming and pc use it
will adjust so you get the best picture
each time the drawback i feel with such
devices would be its audio quality
[Music]
and similar tvs in this range are so
thin the quality of audio can be quite
limited there's a distinct lack of bass
and sound that can fill the room but
it's largely passable spoken audio comes
off as crisp so there's little chance
you might miss a word
yes
even for tenant
that's not possible ten minutes times
time there's some problems
getting out of the life is the problem
however as i'm sitting pretty close to
the tv i don't really feel a need to add
on any additional speakers at this point
of time
when it comes to pixel density
because users will be sitting so close
to the screen it becomes quite obvious
text is less sharp compared to
traditional monitors this is something
folks need to take note of if this is an
aspect that i urge them
personally i work with techs most of the
time so it's something that really stood
out for me
lg has come a long way when it comes to
playing well with others
i even have it connected to my google
home so i can turn it on without having
to reach for the remote this is the
perfect 4k oled display which should be
at the top of your list when it comes to
being future proof the lg c1 has a good
mix of pretty much everything
considering that you'll be getting
plenty of value this makes the lg c1 a
serious contender as opposed to just
getting a monitor
either way this is a buy which i won't
see many folks regretting thanks for
sticking around to the end of this video
if you enjoyed this video do give us a
like and support this channel by hitting
that subscribe button are you
considering getting the lg c1 let us
know in the comments until then thank
you for watching and see you in the next
one
[Music]
you